je vais essayer de me débrouiller tout
seul aujourd'hui
du moment que tout le monde fait ce
qu'il est censé faire c'est compris gk
tennis tour déposé parce que j'avais
tout alors je vous aime et dégager les
trésors à l'union parents comme
absolument urgente à 17 heures oui je
vais te vas trouver une baby sitter un
soin d'eux mêmes à leur excellente idée
il ne croit pas être en retard à mon
premier entraînement de foot de l'année
du désolé je fais ce que je suis bach un
peu plus des forces mais retenir ni la
vente de gâteaux pas de msg pas de bh
annuler bht ni noisette mieux il est ni
beurre ni celle du grenoble et j'en ai
plus qu'assez d'essayer d'être la mère
parfaite
j'en ai marre
on trouve que j'ai toujours ressenti
semblait hier sur le rôle de mère ou
drug c'est chiant impunis baptisant dit
pas non à des amphores
alors si vous en avez juste ras le bol
c'est maman soit disant parfaite qui
vous disent que vos gâteaux ne sont pas
assez bons pour la kermesse de l'école
ou si vous êtes juste une maman qui veut
en faire un peu moins
alors stop soyons des merrains dit je
vais vous détruire
[Musique]
c'est ce type de ta mère c'est mon
soutif hyper sexy on dirait un hyper
lent ni chance et un mono nichons [__]
je les aime tellement je pourrais mourir
à la seconde pour eux cette espèce de
petit [__] à l'université vers beach
années comme un bébé chien
les enfants sont un cadeau du ciel
[Musique]
dopc want you back